a new crisis for the white house less
than two years after biden vowed that
america would be respected around the
world our relationship with china has
never been worse breaking today the ccp
just suspended all planned official
discussions with the united states in
retaliation for speaker pelosi's trip to
taiwan china is calling her visit an
egregious provocation meanwhile china's
biggest ally russia is backing their
dear friend 100 percent unfortunately
putin can only offer a little more than
words because his country's involved in
a prolonged conflict in ukraine
and now with analysis it's going to help
all of us is former massachusetts
senator scott brown along with fox news
contributor and former cia station chief
dan hoffman gentlemen thank you very
much
i cannot believe
that i have to like open a segment for
you two guys talking about how china is
screaming at us and we're like running
away like scared rabbits we've got
conflicting messages coming out of the
white house which said we don't support
taiwan independence which was by the way
a horrible thing to say well nancy
pelosi is going over there hugging them
that alone scott i think would send a
message that the american government is
itself divided on this issue what's your
take on all of this
well first of all i've been to china
i've been to taiwan two or three times
taiwan is an amazing country
they are a democracy that supply a lot
of our chips that we need for our
military and other means and china
they're a big bully if you get off the
plane and it smells like an ashtray the
biggest polluters and they have a three
to six to 900 year plan and we don't
have a plan you see the the the
fractured and the splinter nature with
the biden foreign policy as evidence in
ukraine and now you see it again with
china in in taiwan and the united states
i thought nancy pelosi did the right
thing my only regret i don't agree with
iran anything uh my only regret is she
didn't include more republicans uh she
has the right to travel she has the
right to go to anywhere she wants where
they are the united states of america
and joe biden should not have basically
you know thr thrown her out out the door
and uh
under the carpet and he needs to stand
up to china because they're a bully uh
they're using the wto to take advantage
of uh developing nation status and and
they're wrong so i don't want to take
dan's time but i want to hear it you
know and also
the world health organization is another
example of what china seems to control
that of course did a disservice to this
entire planet uh when covid was emerging
and dan i think we all agree i love that
she was going to taiwan but we presume
that it's an organized dynamic involving
our entire government and everyone is in
agreement and we're not going to display
you know the family fight in front of
the enemy which they then know and i
think it inspires them and they use that
and figure they can even do more and
move forward uh even more aggressively
normally this should have been a visit
that reinforced our our strength and our
support of a friend and would you agree
that it seems to have done the opposite
at this point
well i think that it is a bit disturbing
that the administration was behind the
scenes discouraging speaker pelosi from
making that trip uh but that she did the
right thing i agree that she did the
right thing by going ahead with it i
think the administration must have asked
our intelligence community how would
china respond to this uh to this visit
and what we've seen
uh is an extraordinarily aggressive
asymmetric response you look at
the military drills that started
yesterday that effectively blockade
taiwan until sunday
that is a pretty extreme measure but i
think what china is trying to do they
know that the united states will carry
on with a relationship with taiwan they
are trying to deliver a stark message a
clear one uh to to those countries in
the region and beyond that the cost of a
relationship with taiwan is simply too
high and they shouldn't do it china's
seeking to isolate taiwan
uh fully and this administration i agree
with senator brown needs to push back
with a real strategy to prevent that
from happening all right well what would
that be because when we say that china's
sending a message that the you know
there's the cost is too high to do this
you know what would that cost to be
would they take there are other islands
that are close to taiwan would they take
those
they've stopped talks which they
probably were not really serious about
in the first place what al stam would
they do uh
you know or that they think we might do
uh as a response to this
well they're militarizing the south
china sea and they are uh absolutely
trying to induce
taiwan's neighbors in in the region
diplomatically and other and by other
means economically to isolate taiwan we
need to be more forceful in the region
we need to ensure that freedom of
navigation is upheld in that region uh
we need to work closely with our allies
particularly japan and australia and we
need to push back on china with an
all-of-government approach in our own
country to deal with their
full-throttled espionage and their the
way they steal our intellectual
property and there's a lot for us to do
need a comprehensive strategy to do it
ambassador
what else would you recommend when it
comes to how we would push back here
considering what china is doing to this
country with espionage with hacking of
of of our intellectual property what
what do you think we could do
well first of all as you know under
president trump i served for four years
in the inner pacific i saw firsthand
what they do in that region as dan said
building and militarizing islands
changing the law of the air and law of
the sea an international law that's been
in place for hundreds of years over
leveraging pacific island nations to get
you in votes they're very methodical and
thoughtful they bring in people to to
build a project they bring the people
the food the
the architectural supplies they leave
the people there and they slowly but
surely take over these island nations
one of the things that we need to do is
we need to do free trade deals with a
lot of these individual countries we
need to give them the support for
example in new england new zealand uh
we'd have do don't have a trade deal
it's been promised since 1954. we have
one now a version of it but they need
the backbone and we're not giving them
these these areas the support that they
need from the united states uh you know
uh when we think about backbone one does
not normally think of joe biden
gentlemen thank you very much we've got
obviously a lot on our plate thank you
very much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else